well hello ladies hello
i like your background all the flowers
thank you
i feel like a florist i know
very extra okay so let's talk about a
way
obviously a major part of the show is
your relationship as
mother and daughter um and making that
huge sacrifice to go on a mission to
mars
that would take you away from your
family for three years so as
actors who are sometimes away working on
a project
for months at a time um can you relate
to being away
from your loved ones in this way a
hundred percent i mean now
i've been an actor now for 29 years and
i am constantly going away for a very
long time from my
loved ones communicating oftentimes like
this
different time zones and uh
it takes its toll for for certain
especially when that's like your comfort
you know it's
it's your anchor it's your it's your
home essentially
um and i don't mean the building that
you you know reside in i just mean the
hearts that love you and hold you and
um especially when you're on a set you
know when you're
going through a lot of different
emotions that aren't your own and then
it's hard for you to decipher what's
yours and what's not and uh
um and then when you're tired you know
you feel extra like you need extra
comforting so it's definitely a
challenge that i think that
afforded us the understanding of
for for this show yeah
yeah my little brother's an actor as
well and
it makes it difficult because sometimes
i'll get things here which is nice so i
can be with my family but he normally
books things out of state um and
sometimes that country
and it's really hard because he once
came back
and it was like three months and he was
taller than me
and i was so sad i like cried that night
in my bed i was like
ladies because he's my only he's my only
younger sibling and so he's like
i don't know i feel very protective of
him and so when he came back he was
taller it just makes it so hard because
you feel like you miss big milestones
and yeah it's it's a difficult decision
but it's one um that we are definitely
tasked to deal with and it's a decision
emma has to make and
i feel like they definitely make it
clear that it's that it's not easy
that she goes back and forth and she's
indecisive about it
which is how it would really be yeah
um would either of you be interested in
going to mars
and what is one item you would bring
with you
i would like to go to space
but not all the way to mars i would
change the moon
and uh i would take my dogs who are like
sitting right here in one of them's name
moon and every time
she's like this no
she is the most off topic but she is the
most
precious loyal dog i have ever met she
would just
follow hillary around on set she
wouldn't bark she would lay at her feet
i was just like this is the perfect
animal
ever it made me want a dog
but um i i would bring
my family and if i could only bring a
couple family members i would bring my
nieces
even though they love their mom and they
would be devastated i don't think i
could live without them
you guys are so sweet um for
hillary i know that you know the way
that those sh those scenes were
shot it looked like you were in space
obviously so did you have like a harness
like how did you guys
do that it was it was definitely a
challenge i'll tell you that it's kind
of like patting your head and rubbing
your belly at the same time
because you are you know it just
inevitably when you
start moving slowly you think you have
to talk slowly
like that it really would happen in
space so we would joke around a lot
because as we got tired
we would start changing our voice and
we're like no no
you can talk normal and zero g um
but we would like be like attached at
our the lowest part of our hips and like
act and that would act like a pendulum
for us and so it was
really um a strange um
challenge um indeed awesome
well thank you guys so much jesus that
spacesuit weighed 30 pounds
no well thank you guys so much i just
got the wrap cue so thank you guys for
your time and be safe
you